the two largest US automakers are
stepping up efforts to roll out electric
vehicles General Motors announced it
will introduce at least 20 all-electric
vehicles by 2023 to will come in the
next 18 months Ford created a group
dubbed team Edison to deliver 13 new
models over the next five years these
developments follow news that China
intends to ban gas-powered cars in the
future CBS News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson is
with us good morning morning Charlie so
why are we seeing this happen is it
simply that that is where the action is
and that's simply where the world is
going in terms of electric cars you
better get on the bandwagon now yes and
the reason why that happened is one
Tesla Tesla showed you can make a better
car electric cars aren't toy cars they
can go zero to 60 or faster they can
handle better their huge advantages to
having a battery in the middle of a car
instead of a big explosion engine in the
front of the car that would be Elon Musk
now beyond might against him so they
showed that you can do it and now
everybody realizes oh now the
regulations are following China saying
you're gonna need to have electric cars
California is talking about that lots of
countries are talking about it cities
are talking about what they're gonna do
so that means that people are going to
start have to build the electric cars
which means the infrastructure will
follow so now everybody is realizing
that all the pieces that need to come
together for an electric future are
coming together the cars the
infrastructure of the battery and the
other thing that's happening is that
they're trying hard
including Elon Musk to develop batteries
that will enable them to have even
longer right and that's always been the
thing it's wrong but now you have test
those with you know batteries of 330
miles right so you actually have a
really great battery tech and it keeps
improving and a big battery plant going
up in life yep and places where you can
charge your batteries all over the
country right if you have a great
battery but there's nowhere to charge it
that's not good now that everybody sees
the selected feature people are going to
start putting up charging stations all
over the country I'll make it all easier
so funny I have an event in California
coming up and one of the guests that's
coming said do you have an electric
station at your home to charge my car is
that what it's come to now well ideal so
that's a annoying Gail I have electric
car and I have a charging station yeah
but I mean when you're going to
somebody's house I just thought wow I'd
never heard a question like that that's
because we're in a strange transition
period where things like that happen a
couple years from now there will be so
many charging stations that won't
so is it up for grabs who will be
leading the separate well yes absolutely
okay guys they're in the game right
Jason who I mean this is kind of amazing
this shows the excitement over it dicing
which you think of probably as a hair
dryer and vacuum cleaner company but
thinks of itself as a battery and motor
company is getting in but it's up for
grabs I mean is somebody leading more
likely to dominate well the big question
is Tesla right so Tesla started it
everybody thinks of Tesla they were
behind their product production targets
for the model 3 which has got a few
people nervous Tesla says it's
absolutely fine the question is whether
they can maintain their lead and produce
millions of electric cars every year
which is gonna be does the government
have a say in any of this I can imagine
the oil gas industry may not be too
happy with this track they have a huge
say and they helped a lot so far they're
gonna be a lot of hard tho yeah the nice
thing by electric cars also is that
there's some related to software and you
can change software while you still own
the car yep you can update automatic
license alright Thompson always good to
have you at the table with your snazzy
socks always look forward as he sucks
he's a dapper dresser